- Hallo, ihr Lieben. Kommt rein!
- Hallo!
- Danke schön!
- Wo sind deine Sachen?
Ist das alles?
- Ja.
- Ach herrje!
- Danke noch mal, dass Nico ein
paar Tage bei Ihnen wohnen kann.
- Jaja. Das ist doch kein Problem.
Möchten Sie etwas trinken?
- Ich muss leider sofort wieder gehen.
Ich fahre heute noch in den Urlaub.
Ähm, ich komme bald wieder.
- Okay. Danke, Lisa, für alles.
- Tschüss!
- Wiedersehen.
So, und du!
Was möchtest du denn trinken?
Möchtest du Apfelsaft oder
lieber eine Apfelsaftschorle?
- Schorle? Was ist das?
- Das ist Saft mit Mineralwasser.
- Dann nehme ich eine Schorle, bitte.
- Gut.
- Möchtest du auch etwas essen?
- Jetzt?
- Ja, was magst du denn?
- Was gibt es denn?
- Es gibt Fleisch, Fisch und Gemüse.
Magst du Karotten?
- Karotten …
- Ich esse gerne Karotten. Und du?
- Ich esse auch gern Karotten,
aber Tomaten …
- Du isst lieber Tomaten.
- Ja, ich esse lieber Tomaten.
- Und Kohlrabi? Isst du Kohlrabi
am liebsten?
- Nein, ich finde Kohlrabi nicht so lecker.